breakfast formation I want to see some
real cavemen action out there we do this
fast we do this loud we do this as a
family
and never not be afraid a long time ago
this little bear was alive she was alive
because she listened to her father so
we've gone along just fine with our
brains until now cavemen don't need
brains because we have these
I hope this turns out better than your
plan to cook rice in your stomach by
eating it raw and then drinking boiling
water this plant's nothing like that
plan
po why are you really out here I just
found out that my dad isn't really my
dad your dad the goose
that must have been quite a shock cause
you're blowing up is your thing then you
are in the right place
pretty cool
officer is there a problem but how do a
lion a zebra a giraffe and a hippo walk
into a casino in Monte Carlo tell me one
conceivable way that extra large animals
like us are going to be able to move
through Europe without attracting
unwanted attention oh my God
hold on hold on okay I'm coming right
now don't move sweetie I'm gonna get you
down hold on I'm coming is that a kiss
means everything to us and if you do
anything that threatens this serious
you will have to answer to me
your attention please your attention
please I have an announcement to make
I'm bored
what about all those poor suckers out
there in the audience ah yeah they just
keep praying that their category is next
well as long as they are praying and
while we're at it I get to anoint their
feet you keep your hands off me a little
twinker I'll call the cops my daddy's a
cop his breath smells like cat food
I love you Dad but we don't even know if
the kid's gonna be a vampire I'd be
thrilled if the baby's Humanity just
like Johnny did is it his first word
holy rabies this looks like a blast hi
guys this is so exciting oh look at all
of this so cool wow I can't believe I'm
actually here Johnny Dennis is not a
monster
oh no okay
[Music]
guys listen to me I don't think I'm
better tougher than anyone I mean
believe it or not I fancy myself mortal
buddy wait this this half a snack is a
dinosaur Whisperer just to be clear
that's a pumpkin right in your face face
Rock
scary story you think you can handle it
oh and the zombies don't forget about
the zombies
how'd you do how many volts did you get
I didn't get any vultures but look look
I got a lion what I got a win man that
just seems alive it's breathing the eyes
are moving under its Lids oh my God it's
alive Pumbaa it's a lion run for your
life Pumbaa run for your life
[Music]
Hakuna Matata Hakuna Matata look I can't
even keep counting the steps my body
parts aren't responding okay it's never
gonna happen
bye eggy bye Perry by Carla by Gail by
Rory by Mickey by Mo by Nelson by Hannah
buy test bye bye Casper
Queen Elsa of Arendelle
Princess Anna of Arendelle
there here oh are you sure because I
don't think I'm supposed to oh okay
hi
me
oh hi you look beautiful thank you I
mean you look beautiful or
more beautiful
what is that amazing smell
chocolate
no I know we can figure this out
together how what power do you have to
stop this winter stop me
I think we should go no I'm not leaving
without you Elsa yes you are
do you really believe you can beat us
tomorrow
face it caveman you and your trab you
just don't have it in you
but I am willing to offer you a deal
a way out
[Music]
oh that's good
I don't know what the queen is worrying
about
I mean we all know what losers cavemen
are those Stone Age dolls couldn't beat
their own grandmothers brainless goons
gormless half-wits oh
Stefano not so emphisted in fact enough
massage are you kidding of course I want
to keep racing I don't need a trainer
out here Cruz
well life's a beach and then you drive
well life's a beach and then you drive
this is my last chance Cruz last final
finito if I lose I never get to do this
again if you were a racer you know what
I'm talking about but you're not so you
don't what no no no but we are looking
for a lost toy she's a figurine used to
be on that lamp in the window names Bo
Peep Bo Peep oh yes I know Bo
you do hop on in we'll take you to her
uh um no you don't you don't have to do
that Benson grabbed you well uh okay
don't you know what you are
I know what you are
I know where you came from
would you like to see
yeah
look who jumped 40 school buses and
landed back into my life hi Duke who's
the cowboy Duke beat Woody what do you
mean Duke Kaboom Canada's greatest stunt
man huh oh yeah huh huh yes huh to uh
hold on one more
oh yeah look at us iPods TV pancakes
we're not people we're Birds we have to
go out into the wild and be Birds blue
just let's do it knock knock who
probably is there the interrupting cow
and the interrupting cow
where's my response I was to say the
interrupting okay you did it again let's
see oh oh but that is the joke with the
cow is to be an interrupting cow and
therefore interrupts me I know that's
why it's fun
let me no no Auntie I'm the interrupting
cow knock it off
don't make me get out more tape
mob grub it's a very nice looking group
of PODS do you have a favorite how about
that one this is it
this is the one well well well
the cat was away these mice tried to
play I can do the oof let's try without
Drive
yeah
you're not gonna lose me that easy uh
you might want to keep your eyes on the
road
thank you
yo Department of noise get out of my car
they'll kill the children
that's what I'm saying you'd be dead too
in that scenario I guess that what are
you talking about 12 Fox years ago you
made a promise to me while we were
occasions on that fox trap that if we
survived you would never steal another
chicken turkey Goose duck orb swab
whatever they are and I believed you why
why did you like